c'est avec le recrutement l'autre
immense défi que relèvent nos
entreprises l'innovation comment
préparer l'avenir sans maîtriser les
technologies du futur nos usines des
poussières entièrement leur image elle
travaille avec des universitaires avec
des laboratoires de recherche certaines
ont même déjà adopté l'intelligence
artificielle c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'industrie 4.0 des usines du futur que
nous présente muriel bessat et rodolfo j
[Applaudissements]
notre premier exemple nous emmène à et
quevillon dans le jura
tracy jura est installée ici depuis 1976
on y fait du décolletage c'est à dire
qu'on usines des pièces à partir de
barres de métal en enlevant de la
matière
les clients viennent du secteur
aéronautique spatial médical nucléaire
[Musique]
en 2015 l'entreprise décide d'entamer
une petite révolution en faisant appel à
l'ia intelligence artificielle
on est dans une entreprise avec une très
grande diversité de produits de matière
qui fait que les opérateurs ont des
modes de fonctionnement qui sont issus
de leur formation technique et
aujourd'hui l'ia est pour nous un outil
pour les aider à prendre les bonnes
décisions au bon moment au bon endroit
le problème à régler et très concret
[Musique]
comment permettre aux salariés de
paramétrer ou re paramétrer très vite
des machines pour passer de la
fabrication d'une série de pièces à la
fabrication d'une autre série sachant
qu'ici il ya quatorze mille références
soit quatorze mille pièces différentes
au catalogue
impossible pour l'entreprise de trouver
une solution seul elle décide donc de
faire appel à des ingénieurs de l'ensm
de besançon
travaillons sur l'intelligence
artificielle donc avec cette entreprise
l'idée est de pouvoir récolter la masse
de données qu'ils peuvent avoir en
production et d'utiliser ces données
dans des outils de l'intelligence
artificielle pour leur permettre de
prédire des défaillances futur ou
prédire des contrôles à réaliser sur les
machines le projet est encore en phase
de démarrage un ingénieur a même été
embauché par l'asm est détaché chez
précis jura il ya du verre donc savez
tous les contrôles qui était prévu se
sont bien passées par contre
effectivement on a de temps en temps des
contrôles rouge où ça s'est mal passé
son rôle finalisé sur place que les
chercheurs ont conçu chez eux
le but pour nous est vraiment de nous
confronter à la réalité des choses parce
que travailler sur des ordinateurs dans
notre laboratoire on va travailler sur
des exemples jouer ici on est vraiment
confrontés à la réalité et donc
l'intelligence artificielle a besoin de
ces confrontations à la réalité pour
pouvoir fonctionner correctement
[Musique]
l'aventuré donc intéressante pour le
laboratoire qui trouve une application
concrète à ces recherches
elle semble aussi l'être pour
l'entreprise qui va pouvoir être plus
rapide plus souple et se démarquer de la
concurrence
même si pour le moment personne ne sait
encore si le projet est rentable
la rentabilité d'un projet d'industrie
4.0 est difficile à mesurer nous on
s'inscrit dans la durée on a démarré il
ya maintenant six ans le projet
d'industrie 4.0 et ça va durer
certainement encore longtemps ce qui
compte c'est que ça ouvre le champ des
possibles
notre deuxième exemple nous emmène à
dijon là contrairement à précy jura tout
parent non pas d'une entreprise mais
d'une découverte scientifique
et c'est ici qu'elle a été fait dans ce
laboratoire pluridisciplinaire qui
emploie 300 chercheurs sur différents
sites en côte d'or en saône et loire est
prêt belfort selon travaillons depuis la
recherche fondamentale des principes
fondamentaux jusqu'aux applications
industrielles aux applications
industrielles peuvent être donc dans
l'industrie 4.0 lié à tous les
applications optique développé les
matériaux du futur développer des
fonctionnalités en nautique avec
l'application médecine pour l'énergie
tels que des piles à combustible par
exemple
parmi les chercheurs dijonnais il y à
frédérik bernard lui c'est spécialité
c'est la métallurgie des poudres en
particulier un procédé qui s'appelle le
frittage
l'état initial c'est de la poudre qui se
présentent ici et donc c'est tout devait
être bues dans un moule qui est celui ci
et on voit très bien les grains de
poudres que vous voyez ici on a des
espaces vides et le principe de frittage
ces deux d'éliminer les espaces vides
entre ces ans entre ses vues et grand
coude pour arriver un objet totalement
densifier et la grande avancée de ce
professeur concerne le frittage flash un
système qui permet d'opérer beaucoup
plus rapidement et surtout avec des
poudres très diverses nous ce que l'on a
fait c'est qu'on l'a appliquée sur des
matériaux un petit peu nouveau sur des
poudres très diverses et variées aussi
bien des matériaux métalliques des
matériaux céramiques et de pouvoir
développer des matériaux dits innovants
des matériaux aussi insolite que des
coquilles d'huîtres du cacao du cuir ou
de la corne de vache
produire rapidement des matériaux danse
à partir de déchets la trouvaille est de
taille mais qu'en faire
du coup je reviens vers toi aujourd'hui
pour voir si tu as de nouveaux résultats
de recherche qu'on pourrait valoriser
c'est là qu'intervient un autre acteur
sayans une société d'accélération de
transfert de technologie qui fait le
lien entre les scientifiques et les
entreprises contrôle c'est vraiment de
faire de la détection au plus près des
chercheurs le plus régulièrement
possible donc en moyenne on a une
centaine de déclarations d' inventions
par an sur sur l'assaillant s'est voilà
donc évidemment chacune et analyser
toutes ne m'ont pas aller vers un projet
maturation mais on fait le troll c'est
vraiment faire date élections pour
déposer des brevets mais aussi des
flaques d eau de logiciels une fois la
trouvaille repéré le rôle de saillans
c'est de dénicher l'entreprise qui
pourra en faire quelque chose là aucune
industrie ne semblait capable d'investir
c'est donc sayans elle-même qui l'a fait
on s'est retrouvé dans une situation où
finalement on avait les clients finaux
qui était bien identifiés qui était très
intéressé par part par la technologie et
ses applications mais il manquait au
sein de la chaîne en fait le fabricant
le qu'ils allaient pouvoir produire les
pièces et donc on a on a décidé de créer
une entreprise donc une start-up
industriels pour pour développer la
production de cette technologie
si internet est donc fondée en 2018
la start-up s'installe à montbard dans
une ancienne usine désaffectée
et le fondateur fois demi est un ancien
collaborateur du laboratoire icb et de
sai ans il y aurait pas eu sayans vous
seriez allé au bout de l'idée je serais
allé au bout mais plus lentement ça m'a
fait passer des caps en terme de deux de
mise en contact j'aurais été plus
lentement puis j'aurais peut-être
intégrer des incubateurs qui sont très
très long qui prennent du temps et qui
consomment de l'énergie aie mais j'avais
la motivation de le faire de toute façon
j'avais quelques soutiens industriel
fort j'aurais été au bout mais pas de la
même façon un peu plus de 3 millions
d'euros sont investis dans un four de
grande dimension grâce au système du
frittage flash il fabrique des matériaux
particulièrement résistants des
matériaux qui intéresse le secteur du
luxe l'aéronautique et la défense
notamment
pour bien mettre un moule à l'intérieur
de ce four on va venir appliquer une
contrainte par deux pistons de vérins
qui peut être jusqu'à 320 tonnes et on
va appliquer un courant et en fait on va
échauffés et appliquer la contrainte en
simultané pour obtenir donc ces
matériaux augmenté
[Musique]
e
c'est une pièce à base de poudre on est
venu fuité
à 1000 degrés et a duré environ 10 15
milles
l'entreprise compte aujourd'hui 25
salariés et entend bien se développer
créer de nouveaux produits pour d'autres
clients pour cela elle continue sa
collaboration avec sa fiancée le
laboratoire icb anticipé pour devancer
la concurrence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]